the wall was directed by Doug Liman and
stars Aaron taylor-johnson and John Cena
and is a movie about a wall we just had
a movie about a wall gratefully this
one's a lot better than that this movie
takes place in 2007 near the end of the
Iraq war and two American soldiers are
pinned down behind a very flimsy wall
when one Iraqi sniper starts to talk to
them on the radio playing a mental game
of cat-and-mouse trying to get the
soldiers to show themselves so that he
can finally take them out of their
misery this film I was pretty excited to
see largely because of doug liman
involvement I really liked the Bourne
Identity edge of tomorrow some of his
earlier films like swingers I mean the
man is super super talented and I think
pretty underrated as a filmmaker and
this was a very contained movie it's
really just one location in the middle
of the desert and a cast of three people
and one of them is just a voice on the
radio so it's really kind of the cast of
two people so this is a very small film
compared to what doug liman has done
recently and when it comes to contain
thrillers I've always been a fan from a
production standpoint they can be made
fairly easily when compared to other
films but the emotional impact can also
be really good because you're seeing a
very personal story you're not seeing a
bunch of lands and a bunch of worlds
you're just seeing this one person's
plight throughout something rather
horrible and ever since movies like
twelve Angry Men which is probably the
best contain thriller ever made I've had
a soft spot for him and for the large
majority of this film's runtime I was
fairly riveted Lyman makes the choice to
not Hollywood eyes this in any way he
will take really long takes of Johnson
just making a tourniquet he won't cut
anything to save time he doesn't change
camera angles constantly to make you
feel like you're more invested in
something that simple like making a rope
to try to get a weapon that's maybe far
away and he can't reach it he takes his
time to show all of these events so that
you can really feel the frustration of
our lead character and it pays off
really well because for the majority of
this movie I felt like I was there it's
not quite real time sometimes Johnson
slips in and out of consciousness and we
lose a few hours but for the most part
you feel like you are baking in the Sun
with these two guys Johnson is really
good in this movie there are some scenes
that are rather grueling and disgusting
to watch and
he really pulled it off you feel his
suffering and John Cena really surprised
me
he was likeable pretty much
instantaneously and believable as a
soldier I thought he really sold it so
as for the voice on the radio which is
the main villain of the film kind of
like the Kiefer Sutherland character in
phone booth
this guy is menacing and this is where
the film becomes more interesting for me
because it was a fun thriller but the
added addition of a psychological war
game between these people really
propelled the movie to be something more
exciting than I thought it could be
because yeah there's not that much
action per se in the movie this is a
very psychological movie it's about can
one person who has an agenda break these
other two guys without doing much but
firing a couple bullets and using some
fancy words and the film has a great way
of making you invested where the film
lost me was its third act and since this
is a very short movie that's really just
like its last 15 to 20 minutes man does
this movies fizzle to a very
disappointing finale and I actually kind
of dropped my mouth a little bit when
the end credits came I was like Oh mmm
that's hmm okay I get the message that
Lyman is going for there is a
uselessness to war I think is what he's
trying to say and that sometimes there
really is no point to anything but
watching a film where again you know I'm
not only going to spoilers or anything
but like it just kind of it's like it
was like a firecracker and then it just
fizzled to a dud but I would recommend
seeing this movie because it has two
really good central performances no
one's really talking about this movie
and Doug Liman does a really fantastic
job directing a lot of in action
sequences I'm going to give the wall of
be guys thank you so much as always for
watching I greatly appreciate it I want
to let you know that my promotion with
audible is still going on if you guys go
to audible.com slash Chris you can get a
free 30-day trial they have hundreds of
thousands of audiobooks at your disposal
you can listen to them on so many
different types of devices I've had a
great time going through Stephen King's
library a lot of Star Wars novels are on
this site as well and I appreciate the
fact that they are continuing to sponsor
my video so please visit audible.com
slash
Chris for your free 30-day trial thank
you very much as always for watching
guys if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck menage
[Music]